how can goofy and pluto both be dogs
hello oh wait
for some reason these two iconic disney
dogs can exist side by side in movies
and tv and we don't seem to mind at all
so why is that this strange paradox of
pluto the pet and goofy the humanoid
actually reflects a deep conflict in how
we perceive dogs to see what i mean
let's go on a trip
it's hard to talk about dogs in movies
because there are just so many examples
there's dog companions talking dogs and
dogs playing basketball dogs are so
universal in our movies that even other
animals tend to act just like them
you're such a good boy
yes you are for the vast majority of
dogs in movies they fit into some form
of the pluto archetype the idealistic
selfless loyal best friend in fact many
dogs and movies are almost supernatural
in their ability to sense danger as if
they are innately skilled at protecting
us many dogs go one step further than
the intensely loyal companion and adopt
distinctly human characteristics shorts
like the hardly boys in hardly gold give
dogs the ability to drive cars and solve
mysteries and that's nothing new since
silent movies we found something
charming about anthropomorphizing dogs
as if we're finally seeing them as we
imagine them here we see early versions
of goofy the adaft and bumbling sidekick
who walks on two legs and has his own
house so the simple answer to the pluto
goofy paradox is that pluto and goofy
can both exist because they occupy
separate but familiar dog archetypes but
that doesn't quite do it for me what
especially bothers me is how goofy
doesn't get the same human-like status
as characters like mickey and donald
he's almost sub-human not too bright
clumsy and doesn't get a love interest
in the main cast which also brings up
another popular online debate is it
better to be a goofy or a pluto wouldn't
it be nice to be a lazy pampered house
dog or maybe that's actually worse and
is it fair that pluto has to sleep in a
doghouse and wear a leash while goofy
who is also a dog gets to drive around
in a car and play golf with mickey
unlike a mouse like mickey or a duck
like donald dogs like pluto and goofy
raise more complicated questions to see
what i mean we have to go beyond pluto
and goofy and look at their complete
opposite let me see your squishy face
[Music]
many movies remind us that dogs
originate from the wild and have a
violent side when it's a small dog it's
usually played for laughs but movies
like cucho have a wild dog who goes as
far as murder and it seems that any dog
can go either way in the sand lot the
scary beast behind the fence ends up a
harmless dog and even santa's little
helper the quintessential family dog
becomes temporarily evil at the flip of
a switch we see this transformation most
famously in the story old yeller where
travis has to put down his own dog after
the dog gets rabies the story sounds
like an older version of a movie like
marley and me a universal tale of dog
love and loss but the movie is also a
cautionary tale travis first meets old
yeller in the wild and it's in that same
wilderness where old yeller gets rabies
a disease that literally transforms
domesticated dogs into untamed beasts if
the story was a simple tale of love and
loss then travis wouldn't have insisted
on shooting the dog himself the story is
about love and loss but it's also a
coming-of-age story where travis learns
about the dangers of the wild that at
their core dogs come from the wild and
they can't return to those roots the
fear of the wild dog explains cinema's
fascination with the coming home
narrative the classic story where a dog
gets separated from their family and
must find their way home in these
stories the dog gets pitted against a
hostile wilderness and their inevitable
return reaffirms their destined
domesticity and validates the sanctity
of the traditional american home this
genre seems to exist almost to justify
our relationship with dogs making it
clear that dogs do not belong free in
the wild where they originated but
rather prefer their lives as our loyal
pets so it's no surprise at all that
pluto the quintessential dog has his own
coming home adventure in mickey mouse
mickey's dog gone christmas where he
feels destined to return to mickey's
side so within our portrayals of dogs
lies a subtle anxiety movies remind us
of the wild origins of dogs yet they
also justify their role in our homes and
this uneasy balance exposes the most
important idea when it comes to the
pluto goofy paradox we're not really
talking about dogs we're really talking
about us
the movie fruitvale station chronicles
the final day of the real life oscar
grant iii a 22 year old who was shot and
killed by bar police in 2009. for the
most part the film stays true to what
oscar actually did that day like going
to the store to buy crabs and telling
his girlfriend he lost his job the
biggest creative liberty writer director
ryan coogler took was when oscar
witnessed a pit bull get hit by a
runaway driver and here we see the
implications of the perception of dogs
as wild animals in an interview coogler
explains why he added the scene in many
ways pitbulls are like young
african-american males whenever you see
us in the news it's for getting shot and
killed or shooting and killing somebody
for being a stereotype pitbulls are
often perceived as more violent and
untamed than the average canine and many
countries around the world restrict
pitbull ownership in part for that
reason but a lot of this perception is
based in mythology many studies suggest
that pipples are not inherently more
violent but rather are more likely to be
victims of abusive environments that
lead to inevitable behavioral problems
so by including this moment coogler
forces the viewer to see oscar not just
through his last day but also through a
broader historical context like a
pitbull oscar is bound up in negative
stereotypes that have permeated our
media for decades and those stereotypes
play a role in justifying discrimination
or even harm against them fruitvale
station shows that our portrayal of
certain dogs as wild has real world
human consequences and we can learn a
lot about our relationships with each
other through our relationships with
dogs perhaps my favorite example of a
dock explaining a human relationship is
in the movie roma roma follows the life
of an indigenous maid working for an
upper middle class family in mexico city
similar to movies like parasite roma has
a more nuanced portrayal of the wealthy
the family genuinely loves cleo to the
point that they take her to the hospital
when she's pregnant and bring her along
on their family vacations throughout the
film we get subtle connections between
cleo and dogs the very first scene shows
cleo cleaning up after the family dog
and like the dog she lives just outside
of the actual home in a separate
enclosure near the garage she also must
take orders most notably when marina
yells at her to leave the house and when
she literally instructs cleo to sit at
first glance it sounds nothing but
demeaning to associate cleo with a dog
but it's more complicated than that
after all cleo is treated very well by
the family and she has a comfortable
life compared to other indigenous people
in the film yet the comparison makes
sense because the family does limit her
agency like they do with their own dog
marina does invite cleo on vacation but
cleo inevitably ends up doing chores
when she's there and at the hospital
cleo hardly gets to speak the doctor
talks past her as she relays key
information to marina her employer in
the same breath the kids can praise cleo
for saving their lives at the beach and
ask her to make them a smoothie romo
reveals the complications of the human
dog relationship is it really better to
be a pluto it might be so long as you're
okay with not having much say and being
told what to do and in a way oscar and
cleo share characteristics with goofy
they're human but they're still
perceived as a sort of sidekick a not
quite fully respected person in the
shadow of the default main cast
[Music]
according to disney goofy was created as
a human character as opposed to pluto
who was a pet for decades we've been
comfortable seeing these two characters
side by side because they fit neatly
into our cultural understanding of dogs
dogs as loyal idealistic companions and
dogs as anthropomorphic but
unintelligent sidekicks and these
stereotypes come from thousands of years
of domesticating and loving our dogs so
it's no surprise that dogs have become
such powerful symbols powerful enough
even to symbolize the complicated and
unequal power dynamics between us humans
so the way we treat animals in our media
and in real life matters because the
methods we use to justify animal
stereotyping and cruelty often become
the same strategies we use to stereotype
and dehumanize each other so the next
time you watch a movie consider all the
different ways a dog can go i like this
one the one dog goes one way and here
the dog goes the other way well that's
going to eastern the other one is going
west so what
thanks to everybody for watching and
thanks especially to my patreon
supporters i couldn't do this without
you